welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Lawrence Liang a legal researcher and
lawyer based in Bangalore India known
for his legal campaigns on issues of
public concern he is here at Yale as the
rice visiting fellow in the South Asian
Studies counsel at the Macmillan Center
his key areas of interest are law
popular culture and piracy professor
Liang has been working closely with the
suraíh program at the Center for the
Study of developing societies in Delhi
on a joint research project on
intellectual property today we talk with
him about the recent ruling on the Delhi
University photocopy case thanks my
pleasure to be here so let's begin with
an overview of the photocopy case tell
us about it well what happened was
around four years ago some of the
leading academic publishers Oxford
Cambridge Francis and Taylor filed a
copyright infringement case against a
small photocopying shop at Delhi
University along with Delhi University
and this was about course backs so
typically you know for the graduate
level a lot of the courses are designed
using extracts from different books and
the publishers claimed that this was a
violation of copyright we filed an
intervention on behalf of the students
and on behalf of the teachers arguing
that this was actually legally
permissible in the law and I think the
importance of the issue was that this
was the test case both for India but
also for other developing countries on
what the extent of the fair use
exception in copyright law would be to
facilitate access to knowledge in a
situation where learning materials are
extremely expensive and in a country as
sharply divided as India is this can
mean a great impact on the ability for
students to access learning what do you
think there's a reason the publishers
chose this particular photocopy shop in
the India versus you know something in
part of the world for instance well
absolutely I mean number of reasons for
that one will that the photocopy shop is
located within the university they had a
contract with the University and they
were in fact given library cards which
will allow them to take books before the
start of term to create these course
backs the second is that in a way that
the efficiency of the photocopying shop
where it became the most popular and to
go to place for people and for students
to access material you should remember
that in many libraries in India you have
either a single copy of a book or in
many instances you don't even have a
copy of the book
so come exam time a lot of students rely
on being able to get these books through
photocopy shop like this one okay so
what was the crux of the case the crux
of the case was that there is an
exception in copyright law in India
which allows for the reproduction of the
work for educational purposes and it
literally says reproduction of the work
in the course of instruction the
publishers wanted a narrow reading of
this to mean literally giving a copy to
a student in class and taking it back
from them whereas we were we were
arguing that obviously that cannot be
the interpretation and it had to be on a
much wider terrain the second big issue
was the question of how much you could
copy so as you know in the u.s. in
overall series of cases over the decades
they've laid down a quantitative
restriction of 10% of a book being
permissible for education that's
interesting I did not know that actually
I would have said it was much greater
than that right so that's it in fact
precise question the question is that
for a country like us where the
infrastructure of education is already
very well established if you have a rule
of 10% then the question is would that
be adequate for a country like India
should you have a differential standard
for the developing countries on
education and that's why it's an
important case for the rest of the world
because in a way the globalization of
intellectual property and it is the
global regime has also been accompanied
in a way by the use of standards from
cases primarily from the US and it's
very rare that you actually have cases
from developing countries that lay out
what kind of different philosophical
premised on how we understand copyright
law okay what was I believe it was
justice and laws what was his actual
so just and lo concluded with the claim
that there was no prima facie
infringement claim that had been made
the reason being that if copyright is a
right that's granted by statute it's
also accompanied by exceptions copyright
you must remember began as a law that
wanted to facilitate public access so
the very first copyright statute the
statute of Anne is entitled a law for
the Advancement of learning but over the
decades copyright has primarily become
about the protection of the rights of
private interests and about the rights
in a way of the owners of copyright so I
think it's in the in the manner of
maintaining a balance between public
interests and access to learning
material and promoting creativity while
at the same time ensuring that there are
some incentives for creators of works so
what just landlord did was that he
bought brought this balance together to
say that in the case of Education there
is a policy kind of a you know a premise
which informs why there is an exception
carved out for education and that does
not interfere with the legitimate
interests of the publishers and if that
is the case then they can be no claim
that there was an infringement for
making of course backs okay and do you
think that okay was this solely his his
argument based solely on educational
institutions for instance if I'm a
private citizen and I want to photocopy
you know a book and give it to my sister
for instance well will that fall under
this ruling or no so one major
difference between the US and India in
terms of the structure of copyright law
is that in the u.s. you don't have
enumerated exceptions what do you have a
general principle so there are four
principles that would determine whether
the use of a work is fair or not but in
the Indian context you actually have
enumerated exceptions so there are other
exceptions for private use but that's
primarily for research so if you wanted
to let Li photocopy JK Rowling's Harry
Potter books and give it to someone that
would not fall within fairness the
provision that we were arguing for was
specifically about educational uses so
the question is assuming I want to do in
an English literature course photocopy
two chapters of Rowling's Harry Potter
would that be allowed
the answer was absolutely okay and you
say we did you actually work on this
case yourself yes I mean we were part of
a team that can that consisted of a
number of lawyers advising the students
and teachers even though they were not a
party's with the case our argument was
that this is a case that's about the
future of Education and it cannot be
fought without the voice of students and
teachers being heard one of the ironies
of the cases that the petitioners the
publishers cited the use of textbooks
and academic books by a number of
academics these academics signed on on
the case to say that we do not have a
problem with students using our material
for courses and what do you think the
implications of this ruling will be not
only for India now but also more
globally I think one of the key
challenges in terms of global copyright
and the access to education movement has
been the question of how do you balance
between on the one hand your obligations
under international law because all
countries are a signatory to the TRIPS
Agreement which lays out a common
minimum standard in copyright but at the
same time because the needs of every
country is unique and the developmental
challenges are extremely in a way
individual how do you balance between
your legal obligation versus the
flexibilities that you can use as a
country and I think what this case
leaves down is a very good precedent for
other countries to follow especially
from a developing countries work
perspective on how you can interpret
your laws even while remaining compliant
with international standards okay and in
terms of the publishers themselves I'm
not familiar actually with the legal
system in India are can the publishers
appeal or no well unfortunately the
publishers have already opinion the urge
them once the decision came out a number
of intellectuals including you know the
Nobel Prize when amar TSN when the case
had been you know filed had written to
them as as authors with Oxford urging
the publishers not to you know take this
kind of agnostic stance over the course
of the last four years in a way they've
already
a number of students a number of
academics and so when the judgment came
out a number of us who had written after
the judgement urged the publishers not
to appeal and we would try to make the
case that students and teachers are not
your greatest enemies they're your
greatest allies so you have to think in
a way of how you were to you know create
and think about a business model that
ensures that it's feasible for you even
while at the same time not impeding
access to knowledge
unfortunately the publishers haven't
heeded our call and they filed in the
field so we will have to take this all
the way to the Supreme Court okay do you
think that these publishers have you
heard of any instances of these
publishers starting the same call it
trouble and other developing parts of
the world I think it's important here to
remember that the Indian market is a
particularly lucrative one both in terms
of the size of the student but also
because it's the the primary language of
Education at the university level is
English so in a way this is one of the
most important markets for the academic
publishers which is I think why they
wanted to use this as a test-case this
is of course happened in developed
countries and in the u.s. this has been
happening for many many decades but in
terms of the developing country this is
one of the first major cases okay and in
terms of the appeal what do you think
the outcome will be
well we're hopeful because the judgement
is a very sound one and it's kind of
very solid in its interpretation of the
law they'll be hopeful that this will be
you know kind of it will not be
overturned on appeal how long is the has
the process been in terms of you know
the beginning of the case and then how
long will it the appeal take the case
was initiated four years ago so in
between the initiation of the case to
the judgment at the high court level
it's been four years they've appealed
now to what is known as a division bench
which is a larger bench within the High
Court and assuming it goes our way then
they may appeal to the Supreme Court and
vice versa
if it goes against us but in a way this
is a part of a much larger movement
that's been taking place for the last 20
years and Yale has had a very important
role to play in that because the Yale
Law
school which is very active on debates
on intellectual property from a global
perspective has been crucial and
anchoring an access to knowledge
movement so I think that this is seen
and followed by the global community of
people working on intellectual property
from a public interest perspective so
it's I think it's wonderful that you've
kind of almost come full circle with the
L having started it and you're working
on this case and in the end being here
with us today no it's absolutely for
teachers when we hope that this
collaboration will continue because this
debate is not going to end with this
case right okay thank you very much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thanks Matt for more
information about professor Liang and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you